[Musique]
il se vend dans le monde
un pot de nutella toutes les deux
secondes et demie alors pas étonnant que
d'autres compagnies aient envie d'imiter
cette création de 1946 de pietro ferrero
nous sommes ici vous tout nouveau
complexe à des sciences de l'université
de montréal pour faire goûter justement
4 tartinades choco demoiselle parce que
vous êtes des bêtas ce mardi sur le
nutella sa porte le nom pertinent de
noisettes mais pourtant le premier
ingrédient c'est du sucre c'est plus
sucrés que du glaçage à gratot le but
non
entrée 8 et on est vraiment comme sucrés
mais sans être trop on a beaucoup de
plaisir à manger d'une telle hausse et
c'est quand même un critère important le
goût en gros c'est beaucoup de sucre
parce que quand on regarde ce que c'est
presque 3 cuillères à thé part qu air
assault donc si on se met justement pour
une portion plus réaliste de bonne
cuillère à soupe et ben là on vient de
tartiner notre routine de six cuillères
à thé tuque
faut il partir
[Musique]
la plupart des produits sur le marché
contiennent de l'huile de palme parce
que c'est une huile qui riche en gras
saturés donc très stable à l'air à la
chaleur et à la lumière
un autre atout de l'huile de palme pour
l'industrie alimentaire c'est que ça va
prolonger la durée de vie tablettes des
produits et c'est très abordable
par contre étant donné la demande
mondiale en huile de palme dans les
aliments transformés
ça cause beaucoup de déforestation
particulièrement en malaisie et en
indonésie
[Musique]
l'adhésion de salon
et
georgi sais pas qu'est-ce que ça goûte
on sait très anxieux rigolo mais ceci
rend différent pour une tartinade comme
vous allez à suivre et les acides goût
un peu acidulées c'est peut-être la
poudre de cacao qui est le deuxième
ingrédient alors nous tu y vas c'est un
produit biologique
on nous dit 40% - truc par contre fait
intéressant le premier ingrédient c'est
du sucre quand même donc on ne la moitié
moins de sucre que dans le trailer et on
a ajouté de la farine de l'oeil de
l'inuline pour justement aller chercher
une texture justement
[Musique]
si piqué me pousse des cris aussi quand
même mais un goût de plus sa noisette au
long du mois c'est que c'est un super
sucre et moi j'ai vu bien donc on à la
limite ici sans huile de palme
on connaît bien le lit de la banque de
chaque couleur
donc on à du sucre des noisettes de
l'huile donc dans les huiles on a
tournesol qui art à son de riz pour
justement probablement de aider à la
texture on a vraiment textures qui style
on est vraiment dans le même calibre de
textures que le nutella mais sans huile
de palme
[Musique]
des petits morceaux dedans je pense
qu'il ya peut-être plus de noël par
rapport aux autres mais lui fait plus
comme commandes des soeurs celui-ci
tellement préféré parce qu'ils étaient
jamais envoyé de cibler lips gi oh oui
la texture c'est un produit montréal et
qui contient quatre fois plus de
noisettes que le tlm équipes affrontées
quatre fois plus cher se noyer de la
faire de ce thème je pense envoyer salut
mais les manceaux donc le la cadillac de
la tartinade avec notre 54% de noisettes
chocolat noir donc on donne les
ingrédients qui est très intéressant si
on se faisait une tartinade à la maison
ou mais très probablement ce même même
genre d'ingrédients donc on a trois hits
comme premier ingrédient donc c'est
intéressant
le souk de khan chocolat noir bottes de
cacao vanille flore de ce type
si on regarde oui c'est sucré c'est
quand même le succès quoi cette deuxième
ingrédient ya tellement noisette que
ça finit par être quand même la moitié
du sucre de ce qu'on va retrouver dans
le nutella pour la même dans la même
portion c'est plus cher aussi
mais justement ne plus de noisette le
classique nutella a devancé les produits
de linda est devenue tu vas mais le
grand gagnant aujourd'hui et le produit
avec le plus de noisette
il s'agit de halo simone avec 25 20
[Musique]